hello and welcome to sit you're playing
a beautiful mind mr. and Ronald not sure
i'm not mistaken hmm i see having this
kind of bad reading there he always
plays well against me Jim this is not a
standard line that I do plain but ok
anyway go to minus 1 square again soon
also I feel like I constantly have black
maybe this is a wrong perception but
somehow i think i usually have black
against them ok some rapini he wants to
go night to d5 here yeah but a huge fan
of this position it's more position that
i have with white just want to provoke
him to close that diagonal 95 I go back
to the eighth maybe you don't like it
yeah I just wanted to do something else
I wanted to play gruene felt actually
but he is one of those g 3g three guys
being notoriously solid so you don't get
a proper Greenfeld you get the g3
greenfield and here tried with c5 but ok
anyway I just kind of want to try to
apologize for having a having this kind
of an unattractive positioner at least
to me I don't like it looks a little bit
like a maraca see bind with impending
play g3 but maybe he doesn't have that a
big of an experience in the maracas the
end I can somehow wiggle my way out of
it doubling on the CFR looks a bit
surprising let's say but maybe he
expects to see file to open it then your
future then it makes some sense I don't
see why however that should happen
angling for before maybe okay well here
Q&A five and I think yeah let's not do
fancy primos ok bishops down you
I cannot do much in just have to stay
stay solid him and go from them okay
maybe this one before night be three
looks kind of quirky but 94 is coming
then which could work should work must
work in some way yeah but I think it
does actually work
okay 93 what is the stair okay I have to
play anyway right there's no big old
toilet after that move and I'm can I
mean II cannot pinned me I just take T 2
and then be one is saying as well so
something like hooked queen bee three or
so isn't isn't a problem at all and if I
get 924 I mean that's not so bad so 94
yeah people take this Bishop takes its
there's some issue that I don't see it
like a double attack or something I
don't see it now so i can i can happily
claim to have gotten the bishop am very
nice but still okay 388 at the zoo k 2 1
okay take stakes still 97 so
yeah I guess I have to not happy about
it but i guess i have to i can take on
d5 here and then play with this better
Bishop takes between to be six but it's
not it's not really great can i play i
could do this and actually this is an
interesting entering yeah this is
interesting going for a 5v5 and then
Bishop to see six or ecigs and then take
it playing with the better bishop on the
form he might have some kind of nah I'm
quick enough exchange psych I wanted to
say like takes Queen d2 but I get in
Bishop c6 and then to capture it I don't
know which one as well maybe I will take
any way okay
take anyway and now between f6 or how to
do that I queen you have 60 and trade
let's not make it so easy also hoping
for Lucas and I look at 7am covered I've
got covered very stupid note okay 71
would happen mmm Queen f6 let me start
with this phone okay is called Ruger
three actually maybe look look to see
seven or something okay let's try it
yeah I thought I thought some b5 could
be interesting but it's not rook f3 is a
very good defense here okay just try to
make c5 a possible and I want to go f5
rook f7 this kind of thing if he goes
look a six I go back to my central plan
here with with a queen f6 okay is going
back so let's shoot for it got a huge
time edge time marking not sure this is
right but it will makes it will keep him
under pressure this andrew kev 70 s
dangerous maybe i would win on time also
he was very very very slow okay so yeah
queena for the spin on time wait for it
sometimes he seems to be very slow that
could be leadership with this with this
game why it's not better rated okay it
was kind of interesting I mean I
certainly miss played that opening a bit
probably conceding a Tempe maybe queen
85 this is the combination of Queen 85
and this Bishop many ways and so great
but I mean blacks position is so very
resilient and it felt to me that and he
didn't have such a clear idea what you
doing now he went back to that
before plan okay but now we played it a
true gay three should be enough counter
play yeah because here I'm really okay
94 sir is coming until here I'm fine and
took it and now okay I can take on d5
but I think this is a bit more
interesting to go for this and try to
play with the better bishop on d4
against the worst mission 1 G 2 it's
just that maybe I didn't time that
sucker so so well or here I should go
and fight maybe I was still trying to do
stuff here it this is probably stronger
just pushing this and then you give aid
and therefore and what not yeah I'm a
bit better because this this Bishop is
doing something while the g2 Bishop is
kind of clumsy but it's not it's not a
big deal i think he defended this quite
well and we were probably close to equal
around here the only thing is ok here
and better or queen f four wins already
and to be honest i didn't look that that
hard because of the time time situation
you just play them clearly too slowly ok
well thanks for watching